we looked at the inverse of a matrix
last lesson this idea of if you have
some matrix a right we define its
inverse a with a minus one there
it's not a the power minus 1 but it's
how its price okay such that if you
multiply these two together
what should you get out the other end
you should get the identity matrix right
so you know if it was up
these things were gonna give you a 2 by
2 over here okay that would be I 2 that
would be this I did a matrix that's our
two rows two columns okay so this is our
definition okay now we did it with a set
of numbers I can't remember actually can
we can we see what were they are like
there's a 4 or 5 minus 1 3 news got ya
goin across 3 4 yep - 5 1 yeah okay good
so we had this and then we determined
its inverse right and it had some
fractions it's nothing what do we get
did anyone have it Rondo I did it was
like one - what's you poser okay yeah I
deliberately wanted to make one c40 and
what was its inverse okay great so we
went through the process of putting this
right the original matrix a and we put
it together with the identity matrix
like so okay
we rearranged it and then out came that
and got you know actually we did go
ahead we tested it and when you do that
you just get it as we expected okay now
where I left you
what to say okay this is one thing to do
maths with numbers that's fine okay but
the real test of whether you can
understand something and beneath it is
if you can take it from just a
particular case to a general case like
what if I had any matrix a can I work
out its inverse and there are sort of
clues that we should be able to like
look at these numbers here again just
for starters look at 1/2 at a corner
there sort of in opposite corners of a 2
and a 4 it's kind of
suspicious isn't it right it looks like
they must be relationships here if only
we can work out what they are all right
so I said if I gave you a an arbitrary
matrix might say let's define a as I
write a little bit ABC okay
my question was can you work out what a
inverse is okay so today I'm going to
show you how I did it and it takes a few
lines but there's a lot of symmetry to
it so you'll see the way it works so let
me get the concrete one off the board
okay okay so if that's a I need to
determine what a inverse is and I'm
going to be searching for four numbers
okay because as you saw you know if I
start with this and I put next to its
identity matrix then clearly its inverse
will also be two by two okay so I've got
the same dimension now I don't know what
these numbers are there's something else
so I'm going to call them P Q yes I
don't know what these numbers are that's
what I'm trying to determine now just
watch out before I go any further what
I've got here right these four numbers
plus these folders
it seems like I've got eight variables
right but I don't really have eight very
much like these four up here they're
actual numbers like 1 2 what they give
you 4 and 0 or something like that ok so
these numbers even though I'm writing
them as algebra these numbers are known
these numbers are under okay so I'm
solving for P Q R and s and everything
will be in terms of a b c and d does
that make sense
ok so here's the way I'm going to
approach it my first approach might be
to do what we did over here right and
have an ABCD
like so right and then you try and
rearrange it multiply divide do whatever
you like so that you can get the
the matrix over here and get something
else Ignis over here okay did anyone try
that okay and you got there okay now I'm
gonna ask you to arm show us afterwards
how much work your approach took versus
this one and we'll see which one came
out on top I'll only show you this way
because I think it's a little easier to
understand and I think the algebra we
will be a bit simpler but I don't know
if it's faster so we'll find out he's
all we're going to do I'm gonna take
this definition here right if I multiply
these two together I should get the
identity matrix right so that's telling
me this
therefore by definition a b c d
cross-multiply p q r s shrieking yes
okay now what should you recall how does
cross multiplication actually work
what's the process by which these
numbers going to get up to get these
good good you remember here we go across
the row down the column okay and we
would do that each time we do it four
times and each of these is what we call
a dot product you remember that now in
going from this side to this side these
four dot products represent four
equations right four equations four
unknowns okay I'm just gonna do two and
then you see how the other two come out
just by symmetry okay so for instance
let's have a look at this son this first
dot product which should be one okay I
go across the road that gives me a and
then P plus what's next B times R across
the road down the column okay that's the
first opera that should be one yeah keep
going across the road but down the next
column right I should get let's see so a
queue right next column over plus B yes
right what's that going to equal to
as next time cousin zero right I have
two equations this is good I will go
down to the next row to get the other
two equations right so I'm gonna go
across this room now see P D uh-huh
right that should give me zero as well
and then my last stop product this guy
over here C Q plus D that's gonna give
me one okay so have a look at this right
I could name these one two three four
but you can be a little more clever
about it might think about it I've got
four variables to find but do you see
the kind of impairs because over the way
that I do the dot price look at these
two here you see these two remember a B
and C a B C or D I know what those
numbers are I'm not trying to find what
they are okay but these two equations
here give me P and R right so I'm gonna
call this one equation one and this one
equation two right that's just two
equations with two variables does that
make sense
accordingly I'll call these three and
four but you will see what I do with one
and two will be exactly the same as what
I do with three and four because it's
literally the same thing with different
letters okay so now focusing on these
two it's great one there's equations we
started this is very appropriate we
started looking at matrices by thinking
outside will taste equations so if I
shouldn't do these two what would be
your first strategy for how to solve
these you have to one of the two
strategies sometimes we need either
elimination or substitution which do you
think is a better option I lean towards
substitution you remember either the we
fight but just some are a bit easier in
enough now to do the substitution you go
in either equation one or equation two
but I think the equation true might be a
little bit simpler because you can see
there's a zero on the right-hand side
there so when I rearrange this thing
you're gonna end up with something that
doesn't have that one flying around okay
so
for instance what I could do here is I
could say off of equation one right
if I move that dr over the other side
I'll get CP equals minus dr right so all
I need to do here is divide through by C
and now I have P by itself right so I'm
going to take that which is just an
equation two and I'm gonna pop it into
equation 1 right so if I do some into
equation one right here
I'll write a outside of minus D 1 C o
plus V R so you can see we've achieved
the substitution here which eliminated
out the paint's got rid of it so this is
just a single equation in a single
variable I can solve it okay just got to
be careful with my algebra key so
multiply through by C which gives you
minus a plus B C R equals C okay so far
so good
and now over here I have a common factor
of ah yeah and I've got minus ad plus BC
all noticing okay so I only need one
more step now for reasons that will
become clear by the end of the
construction of the inverse I'm going to
take out this minus sign here and I'm
going to put it on the top on the
numerator which leaves move ad minus BC
on the denominator okay
so this is great I found one term in my
verse matrix and now it's just kind of a
process of working out the rest the
other I've defined the other terms the
first term I can find is P because it's
matched up to R right
so if I substitute into here let's call
this equation two a if I sub into 2a
okay P is going to be equal to minus D
over C times this right so that's minus
C on a
- see the seas are gonna cancel the
negatives are going to cancel and I'm
left with this okay so now I've got P Oh
God ah and if you go through exactly the
same process of substitution and
simplifying things out you will get Q
and s as well this is gonna be your
result you're gonna get the inverse be
equal to okay this is a right we just
worked that one out
ah this down here - see and if you
follow through with the algebra you
don't what you'll find is we get minus B
over here okay and what's great about
this is you can quickly check how it
works with the previous example that we
did right I think what we had was one
two four zero down was hey okay so a
inverse is going to be well you can see
ad minus BC which I'll come back to in a
second that comes up again and again and
again so I'll just work that out for
starters ad is zebra minus BC is
negative eight so everything is going to
be divided by negative eight because it
comes up with the denominator over and
over again okay so this will be divided
by negative 8 divided by a rage Hey /
maybe eight and now all that's left is
support me an A - B - C and D right hey
- B - C and D okay which if I simplify
that sorry it's a bit messy zero divided
by whatever and this is going to be a
half this is going to be a quarter and
that's negative 1/8
exactly what we were expecting okay so
that's it
it was hard up but it's totally doable
and before we finish here I just want to
point out to you that this denominator
right
it comes up repeatedly so clearly it's
important right it's so important it
gets its own name and its own bit of
notation
okay so a D minus BC we call it for
matrix a we call it the determinant
determinant feels a little bit like the
discriminant in quadratic equations
right I determined something we're
waiting till next term to actually work
out what it does determine but we get to
it later the notation that we can use
for this is an A with bigger or a Zadeh
the matrix right and then these big bars
on either side that's equal to ad minus
BC that's the determinant so I could
rewrite this in a much more concise way
I can write this as d on the determinant
minus C on the determinant minus B all
over em a and that's the inverse